all right well game two just started and
if levon aronian wins this game he will
win the fdx road to miami what's
happening on the board so we see the
modern defense
one we very rarely see at the top level
these days because it is so risky it is
really provocative as black black's not
fighting for the center at all white has
this nice pawn center uh instead black
just kind of creeps forward
puts his bishop on a decent diagonal and
uh okay this last move by ironian
this shows he or just wants to play
solid chess
what do you think of this opening choice
from where you simon
yeah i mean we once had a bit of a clash
in in the modern didn't we that was one
of the only times i managed to get
something against you
and
i mean it clearly
indicates that um
he's going for the win he knows it's a
risky opening
in general the setup that black's played
is very cramped um you give away look at
white center white center is fantastic
two pawns there uh controlling you know
a lot of squares so that's why it's
risky because you're just you know
you're probably just slightly worse but
he's got to take risks now having two
blacks left and he's got to get two and
a half at least out of the last three
games so he needs to win uh one of those
games at least uh with the black pieces
and uh um you know that that that is
something i'm sure level be quite happy
to see as well because he could clinch
it in this game and
i just wanted to mention that that that
little porn move that uh lavon ronin
played it's his pet variation he's
played it three times before three
victories
and uh he will have fond memories here
and uh now the game is developing with
black challenging in the center
and uh this knight coming to the e7
this knight coming to the e7 square
that's a little bit unusual actually
it's not the most popular line
yeah flax lights are a bit passive i
guess
um some at least hold in the center for
black
he's hoping that white closes down the
center at some point that would really
be nice for black
if white closes the center black has
more flexibility black can push his own
pawns forward on the king side perhaps
but levon is not going to break the
tension he's going to keep those two
white pawns side by side for as long as
possible re-rooting his knight meanwhile
levon loves this setup he just loves
putting a bishop in the center we've
seen it in the
kind of uh e45 type of openings we've
seen it in the sicilian he finds ways to
do this as white and he we see it now in
the modern defense
just this kind of night duo perfectly
poised yeah i mean if you put black's
pawn in the center back one square uh
the opening is actually what we call a
hippo and the general rule is any any
opening named after animal is rubbish
so um if you can think of a can anyone
think of it good you know good animal
that's actually a good opening dragon
that's rubbish
and the dragon's not really it's a
mythical animal i suppose yeah
yeah all right okay
all right you're not supposed to use two
examples that quickly
that obviously didn't work very well um
to explain why it's a hippo normally if
black's porn were just one square back
black would be kind of wallowing in his
first three ranks
like a hippo would do in the water or in
mud they just wait and wait and wait and
then when their prey comes forward when
their prey comes too close to them then
they come out of the water and grab you
is that one of your favorite openings
david my favorite especially in blitz
chess speeches it's super effective if
your opponent isn't
familiar with the plans but uh also look
at this kind of
symmetrical setup it's just easy to
pre-move especially in online blitz
that's why i love it yeah but i mean
well a couple of developments have
happened so the center has been closed
black's pawn came forward and levon said
okay give me the space grabbing the
space blocking this bishop
and we're gonna maybe see a king's
indian type of setup um we've seen
reminiscent uh
i mean we've seen
similarities here with the king's pawn
openings now we see similarities with
the king's indian defense where black
has this set up the bishop in front of
his king and he wants to break out
on the king side but this is actually
not normally a good idea when white
knight when the two white knights sit
on these squares if you play on the side
of the board the white knights will be
ready to actually attack the black king
so
yeah computers always hate this type of
structure when white gets a space
advantage with these two
against maybe these two
the white pawns just clamp down on
everything and levon says okay i don't
really care i'm just going to step back
if you want to explode open the position
and go
on an attack i will just take your pawn
and for example if black recaptures the
white knight starts leaping forward
some attack maybe against the black king
levon actually plays some of these
setups as black himself as well so he's
very familiar with the types of ideas
and in the current position
what do you think simon ivanka are we
going to see where ye
go all in right now
i have pulled forward i suspect so i am
i have to say and uh the idea that you
highlighted is very instructive because
i know a lot of us and uh surely a lot
of viewers at home will always feel this
fear about that black pawn advancing and
will feel a sense of panic
and to have a kind of a remedy to this
pawn break is quite handy to have in
your arsenal yeah i mean white's knight
could also come this way and this pawn
is attacked three times
it just feels really weak for black to
be honest compared to a normal king's
indian where whites may be distracted on
the other side of the board already
normally black's bishop as well has
played slightly better here it's just
staring at a pawn
yeah it just feels a bit loose so i'm
not sure whether now's the moment but if
you don't play it now what else do you
do
for ye big question yeah big question i
suspect some more maneuvering some more
kind of mysterious movies might happen
and then as david says there will be a
porn break has to be that way
and uh
well that way he
has to be that way
way yeah yeah
he's got such a great name for pogba
yeah
and uh anyone else who has a great name
apart from wesley so
wesley sawyer
ding of course there must be lots of
good names out there for puns
my mind's gone blank yeah well duda has
the song
sometimes i say howler
but yeah yeah
so that's quite nice i have a cousin who
has that dj howler that's his name
really yeah
didn't find his music ah
is he on spotify i think so okay i'll
check it out
but uh yeah at the moment this is not
the way that he would have wanted the
final to go and it just depends i think
i would
be so tempted to play this move now or
at least it maybe expand on this side of
the board
potentially you could argue that black
spawn can come forward and you can try
and create a square for your knight but
it is a bit weakening
yeah i mean i was going to say like the
setup the white's adopted here is
actually really worth remembering
um
against the hippo because the hippo is
actually it's a pretty underrated
opening and it's going to be my next
chess ball course because i i play it a
lot as black as well and um i remember
luke shane you know talking about
english players he he often plays it in
must win situations because
you keep all the pieces on the board um
but the way that white's set up is
really really good setup actually
because you kind of stop a lot of these
breaks those knights
are nicely positioned uh you can use
your h pawn i mean if you can move the h
pawn to you know all the way up there
you get an ideal situation because then
you really
one break you've got to stop is that one
that david has demonstrated multiple
times that f pawn this one here coming
forwards this is really the only way
that black can get sufficient counter
play i think without that move black is
just cramped and white's always better
so
so yeah just remember to set up if
you're playing against a hippo it's
bringing the knights around putting the
bishops like this i think is is a great
way to play uh yeah i mean it's tough
yeah because you know he needs to
he needs to do something in this
position because white's got many and he
has played it yeah i think
understandably
yeah and okay he takes back with the
knight so the idea of
the pawn capturing and maybe white's
knight coming to the edge of the board
trying to break through on this square
maybe this was just a bit too scary but
he has prevented that with his last move
knight takes pawn if we see a knight
trade now then neither of white's
knights can jump forward one is gone and
this square is no longer available
because the black queen covers it
so white tonight is a bit stuck and
actually black has great chances here
because these two pawns
are very nicely placed very flexible
they can step forward so i don't think
we'll see a knight exchange from levon
ironian the reason
uh they used to tell me when i was young
that every russian schoolboy knows you
should capture with a pawn on f5 you
should capture towards the center to
control all these squares uh so the
reason this uh
is the case is because in the current
situation wei yi took with the knight
clearly in russia uh in russia they
teach things different to china but uh
here white has a really nice outpost on
the e4 square and it's into an eternal
outpost the white knight can plant
itself here and this will never ever get
kicked away it also attacks some really
nice pawns but meanwhile okay it looks
like we're mixing all the openings
because white's pawn steps forward and
black
maybe trying to break down this pawn
chain he's just given up a pawn and this
is reminiscent of the benko gambit oh
so we've kind of had uh modern that
turned into like a hippo that turned
into like a kingsport opening that
turned into king's indian that's now
turning into a benko gambit it's like
all the openings thrown into one
chameleon
uh yeah and what do we think about uh
where yi changing the nature of the
position because now
it's become very very dynamic yeah yeah
i quite like it i mean he's got to win
um i think both players playing quite
sensible lev
i think has done the right approach your
opponent has to win the black let him
over push let him extend himself which
he has to do and uh wei yi has
sacrificed to pawn but you know he's
he's got uh
all the pieces on the board some dynamic
play and some sort of typical uh benko
ideas i guess white must be better
though saying all that white must be
better in this position definitely porn
up and nicely centralized pieces that
we've been talking about okay he pushes
this pawn forward that's really risky
but i guess his idea is if the white
pawn steps forward to attack his knight
he can actually safely just play pawn
takes pawn because there is a pin on
this file the black knight cannot be
captured because the white rook would
drop on a1
wow so complicated yeah this is a big
game i mean this could like this could
end the match this game now
because lev has
gone for this type of position where ye
has over-extended himself but you know
where he's kind of now in a really uh
all-in situation yeah um
and you know i mean
white is better but it's very tactical
very complicated here yeah
and uh it seems like a level neroni and
it's just so not faced you know he's
clearly thinking i know and this
position is so wild i mean it would have
been a good investment of time just to
just think about the position for a few
minutes and decide where the pieces are
but
um well
simon said he likes swinging rooks or
rook overs rovers and uh there we have
warner's as well you know the rook
steps forward to the a3 square
maybe threatening to go all the way to
the right
and again
such a crazy position yeah
are you proud of that move simon is
unworthy of joining the uh
[Laughter]
sorry david can you just say that one
more time a bit slower
can aronia and lev join the swingers
club
well we haven't
can you do it for me david last day can
you ask him if you can join the swingers
club we'll see um
i i do like that movie it it's very
typical in in this situation and it's
just yeah i mean the rook has that
opportunity which david has as
beautifully demonstrated they're coming
all the way to the king's side for
example yeah and
you often find that it's black's king
which will end up being in a lot of
trouble uh later on and maybe that that
line you just demonstrated well okay the
queen covers it but you get the general
idea it's just a good move to improve
your position improve your pieces and
it's now back on black he's a pawn down
and he's got to demonstrate something
here um
i mean what does he can't take the pawn
in the middle i mean that's the poison
pawn um
what else can black play here david um
or anchor
this would this would walk into a pin as
you mentioned simon and if you take the
other way then i guess the knight is
destabilized which and uh once it moves
the bishop in the center will be loose
can you see an idea because i'm
struggling
you know because you know i was thinking
initially yes you know but the knight
can just jump forward attack the rook
but that's not a helpful move either
because the knight is totally unstable
once the rook moves the knight is forced
back so we can probably strike that
option from the list but then again what
else to do because black's uh pieces on
the right side his king is so vulnerable
and he you can see there he took a step
back for the nut yeah but now david's
moved surely
look at that light squared bishop that
white has
that is a killer piece i mean give up
your center it doesn't matter if you're
going to check mate and
the white bishops are both pointing
towards black's king the white knights
are both hanging around black's king the
white rook can swing over and the white
queen that's nearly every single piece
is suddenly uh homing in on the black
king and andrew porno so pawn up with
the attack at the moment this is this is
this is if he plays that move i mean
doesn't that move just look fantastic
it's beautiful i've got to say i don't
really see a reason why not to play this
move how do you even defend this pawn as
black it's not easy at all it's attacked
twice now from knight and from white's
bishop if it steps forward then if you
leave some really weak squares in your
camp the white knight can jump in
we know what we say about the knights in
f5 and
yeah i mean if this pawn is defended by
the black rook the other white knight
jumps in to attack it getting ready to
swing the white rook across
this gains time how else do you defend
this pawn do you have to slide the black
queen across for example but this looks
a bit kind of shaky as well with the
black queen now on the same file as a
white rook it feels like all the tactics
will work for white white's knight can
jump in maybe into the center
i mean just again even at the cost of a
pawn even if black can defend everything
just swing the white rook across feels
like a
pack of cards right now just a tower of
cards ready to collapse for ye
the computer says plus four which i'm a
bit surprised by that it says that much
but that must mean there's already a
knockout blow for white and
i mean if this isn't it then what else
it just looks fantastic
now i just checked the computer
evaluation
that night moved to the edge of the
board
it is a winner it wins yeah it's just
and it's so natural it's the first move
that came to your mind right simon yeah
yeah i mean you'll be showing it david
for a couple of moves already now i mean
you just increase the pressure on
black's weakness i mean it's it's a move
that
lev will obviously see here i mean uh
you can't miss such a such an obvious
move when you set up like this there's
probably other good moves here as well
um you can push the pawn to that square
um you know similar idea on the light
squares
but they just they just don't look as
strong do they why why not start why not
create a threat
a consistent like logical follow-up it's
basically just flowing from what he did
in the opening he put his knights on the
side of the board he lifted his rook up
the board he put his bishops on these
attacking squares like you said and the
next logical consistent follow-up would
be okay let's go for the attack
so it's kind of he's done step one step
two step three it would make sense to
make step four now and go for
the black king
do you think he's uh because lavon
aronian has taken a pause do you think
he's just
calming his nerves because of obviously
when you are winning you get into a
state of over excitement yeah
yeah i mean i think it's i think you
mentioned ivanka you asked him do you
get nervous and he's like no
so i i mean i and the way he
you know his body language does kind of
indicate to me that he really doesn't
get that nervous
um
maybe he's seeing some other tempting
options here uh that's the only other
thing i can think of why he isn't
playing that move immediately um oh
right well that's that's that's very
surprising he didn't play the knight
over there
so logical and didn't seem to have any
drawbacks but instead he kind of semi
defends this pawn it is still attacked
three times
so a bit of calculation required here
um can black take this ball and i'm
guessing with the bishop because i'm a
bit worried about getting pinned along
this diagonal
so
maybe taking with the bishop right now
at least black gets if black can survive
i'm not 100 sure he can over the next
few moves it looks very loose for black
but if he can then he has three
mobile central pawns
to at least try and push later
i'm not a massive fan of this one as
white no no definitely not i mean it's
it's not a very aggressive move he
should have gone for the more aggressive
move definitely
maybe that is a sign of nerves that one
yeah just like you said he played
basically instantly level up to this
point he built up a winning position
he spent barely one minute on his clock
and then uh finally he slowed down spent
three four minutes and
not the best move not the most at least
not the most consistent either
so very surprising yeah surprising and
whilst the players are thinking and why
he is considering whether he can grab
the pawn or not um well we are having a
selfie competition
and we are asking you how to show us how
you are watching us in the tour and john
brazel says that he is watching the show
from the on this glorious sunday morning
in the park
oh you know so and he's also cheering
for
it's a big levon fan there and uh cosmos
says and yet another tournament round
one day you win one day you lose could
you remember cosmon yesterday he played
he won quickly and uh tuned in to watch
the show today unfortunately it was a
bad day
but uh good game good thing it was a
quick quick game yeah which is also good
news yeah and uh okay we have a move
from way he did not grab the pawn and
instead he just reinforces the the
protection of the g6 pawn
okay interesting we mentioned this type
of move earlier but it is purely a
defensive move
i guess black's also hitting the white a
pawn on the edge of the board i'm using
the black rook now using the black
knight using the black queen on a
diagonal
how does levon react now it's less
tempting to jump to the edge of the
board with the white knight because
everything's covered there quite like
this move i mean the the queen is
finding a better square yeah he can also
come over
in front of the black rook and place
more pressure on the center along along
the half open line and um i i'm starting
to think that that that one move from
lev is uh
is giving actually where you quite quite
quite an okay position yeah i'm saying
that quite softly because i'm not
entirely sure
but when we see the evaluation bar it's
hard to be too optimistic about black's
position but it is it does look better
than it did yeah and and here's a pawn
down so the evaluation bar is always
going to be a bit wonky here but the
pawn down maybe not so important with so
many pieces on the board and
chances but i i i things have got better
for weigh year over the last couple of
moves there's no doubt about that and uh
um lev's now gotta
really work out what his plan is because
his last move was just a defensive move
he didn't take the opportunity uh when
it was there yeah
yep it's true what they say you know
sometimes chess is all about timing and
i always think about that
eminem song you know you lose yourself
that one shot that one opportunity
and uh unfortunately it has really bad
chorus
you can't you can't have that one in
your mind when you're playing chess
you've got to lose yourself because you
can't have the words you're going to
lose yourself because then you'll think
about losing and then that you might
manifest that one so
they i do get quite a lot of mlm songs
stuck in my head during chess games do
you
yeah there's
be careful about not saying sing all the
lyrics to them
there's one about mushrooms which some
reason stuck there i don't know it's
like just like
i can't remember the name of the song
don't know where that came from
but he's played this move now but i mean
it's strange
isn't it david you know he's done this
now why why is he doing it now when that
pawn
is defended
um really surprising
maybe he's just kind of his rationale is
that
okay what else is there for white you
kind of have to go for the blacking at
some point otherwise your center might
collapse your queen side
it's a bit shaky with white
yeah maybe he just decided there was
nothing better
or maybe the move was just wasn't on his
radar last turn
and now it is but
wow say surprising and okay one of the
white pawns drops it's level material
again
when he's playing on that side of the
board though when the other side is very
shaky isn't he a bit
it's a bit stretched there isn't he
maybe yeah now that was my vibe as well
immediately i thought hang on a second
that queen could be overloaded you know
she has to protect the g6 pawn she has
to protect her rook but uh i think the
tactics are
working in black's favor there
that was it
my fault by eminem
the song yeah yeah
that's the one it's better than his
first album right he has a lot of
aggressive music i think i think it is
from his first album that one or one of
his first album yeah definitely anyway
let's uh because the position is super
wild let's get right it's really heating
up guys so uh we do see a rook trade and
big question does black take back with
the queen or with the knight if you take
back the queen
you do abandon your king side uh firstly
this square under attack maybe the white
queen jumps in
threatening some really nasty checks
it's uh i mean it's all about the black
king yeah and it does feel like okay he
did take with the knight instead of the
black queen but it does feel super shaky
this is on the edge of the board far far
away from the real action that's gonna
happen on the king side
and how does white break through how do
we justify the plus three almost plus
frame evaluation for white wow
there must be something
is it just bringing the white queen in
the white coat i guess this gets kicked
back
by the black bishop go the other way
could you go the other way so on the
light squares
this way yeah light line it up though
yeah line it up
hit this pawn it's attacked three times
can the black rook defend this is ugly
it might be necessary right just to
defend the square the one thing again we
don't want to allow is white's knight to
jump in to the dream f5 square okay he
actually chooses a different square for
the white queen
sneaky stuff
hitting the bishop unprotected piece
maybe
the white rook is no longer going to
swing across the board but maybe the
white queen sometime can kind of join
the action from this angle later
first how do we deal with this bishop
actually i'm thinking about it this
knight on the edge of the board is
completely trapped so black has to be
careful here
wow so you have to be very accurate
where you put the bishop then because as
you point out
you could lose that night yeah yeah i
mean there's some trouble with the bat
yeah so knight takes pawn in some
positions as well yeah i just uh he has
dropped it back dropped the bishop back
to a safe square and knight takes pawn
you mentioned simon distracting the
black queen so after a trade here will
we see it
suddenly the black queen is overloaded
she can take the white bishop but then
she loses the knight on the edge of the
board and white is a safe pawn up
but then black does have the bishop
power i guess not completely dead yet
okay now he drops back
what is this levon's kind of changing
his mind on every turn he hit this
bishop away from i guess a decent square
but now he's stepped back contact this
board kind of clever right because he's
pawning the centers under less pressure
yeah meaning to see the clever
or not it's one of those cases where and
yeah like you say though this is the
only way to defend it is root moving
this is an ugly ugly rook move to play
but
why how does white make progress now
yeah white needs to somehow get this ro
uh get this bishop get this rook into
the game yeah those are the only two
pieces that are currently unemployed i
suppose you can just move them then
simply lift it up get rid of this
defender maybe it is do we think the
tournament's going to be over
with this game and we would what does
everyone feel that way yeah
would you reckon do you reckon this is
going to be the last game with this uh i
don't know actually i mean because i
think yeah we're all
especially me and i'm seeing the
evaluation bar and i'm saying okay white
is winning white's coordination looks
fantastic but then again there might not
be an immediate win and this might
frustrate levon so i'm going to err on
the side of caution and say
i don't think this is going to be the
last game okay david
i think it will be just because when
we've seen the clock stick down and both
sides being lower on time levon's nerves
have been stronger yeah that's true and
it does feel like if he can
find a few accurate moves now
if he can hold an advantage when they
both tick down under two minutes then
he's a big favorite i think levon
aronian
but yeah we'll see i mean
next three or four moves if he doesn't
find anything as ivanka says there's
nothing direct and he gets frustrated we
could see a turnaround
okay he drops the bishop back that's
clever i guess creating a square the for
the white knight we mentioned the
outpost that the bishop was previously
sitting on the white knight wants to use
that square now
the white knight on g3 wants to hop into
the center attacking black's rook
attacking some key pawns
that looks clever yeah yeah i like that
i didn't see that at all very nice
yeah
and uh
wow this pieces are just clumsy
maybe it's now time for way ye just to
actually do something about the night
that's stranded no but he uh pushes the
form forward attacking the knight
but it does lengthen the diagonal for
the bishop
which
if i were playing with the white pieces
i would feel immediately quite happy
about that
yeah so big question do we jump into
that beautiful f5 square do we just
retreat the white knight
a couple of choices here
that knight on the edge of the board
attacked
yeah i guess yours look at going
forwards first i mean you know if you
can
uh and
i think multiple exchanges are okay but
yeah i don't know f for forward so f5
square that looks very sensible
looks like the most obvious only way to
not retreat but to jump in
i guess the one thing that will make him
hesitate is the black's piece is a bit
cramped so maybe he doesn't want to
exchange pieces but okay he goes for it
too tempting
we'll see black's knight eliminate uh
that piece
yeah why the knight why is it the knight
he will use to eliminate it black light
squared bishop i guess just controls all
the light squares
if you trade off black's light squared
bishop there's a chance that white queen
and bishop are lined up on the light
squares will be able to sneak in a bit
later
usually i don't know why it's maybe it's
a bad habit of mine but when i look at a
bunch of captures if i got two pieces a
knight in a bishop that can capture the
same thing i always think nights before
bishops
and i don't know why it's just an
instinct i mean most of the time it does
work out that way a knight capture first
is more logical but
occasionally you've got to flip the move
order so bishop the black bishop on c8
taking the knight also
quite logical
what will we do lower the clock again he
has ticked under five minutes wei yi
it's not a must-win situation but uh he
cannot lose this game and he takes with
a knight
yep now what'd you take with this
question i mean i i would probably take
with a bishop here without thinking
because i want to get the light squares
in the middle but i would take with the
night without the yeah but i'm thinking
maybe that night soon but okay it's for
your one time clearly
you would love on kindred spirits and
the evaluation bar drops
but i mean you make a good argument here
because white's knight on this square we
could see the exact same position but
with white light squared bishop on this
square instead of white's knight and we
did talk about f5 we see the patterns we
know how effective those knights can be
yeah
that is pretty much an outpost for the
white knight defended by its queen
i was just thinking you know why could
start to get an eye and grip on the
position you know you can see a position
you kind of kind of envision envision a
future where the queen just steps
forward protects the pawn the night is
reinforced and maybe the rook will just
swing over to the left okay this
requires
some help and for black to do absolutely
nothing
but
okay yeah he steps back with the knight
which i also quite like you know again
just keeping control on the position and
if you still manage to utilize the plan
of developing the night dark square
bishop get the rook over to the left
this is uh just domination it is and uh
we could imagine a situation as well
black ends up with a really bad bishop
for example say we give a few moves to
either side here and uh we see a trade
of bishop for night this is what we
would call a good night against a bad
bishop because black's bishop will never
break out from behind its own pawns
really
at least not without giving up material
and white's knight has access into all
the light squares
and this is just beautiful for white so
in the current position
where he needs to be the quick one he
needs to do something he's attacking
this pawn now with his queen move this
is one you highlighted earlier simon the
queen sitting on a decent square now
so i mean he's holding on well isn't he
where he i mean
i i think his you know his chances have
got better to hold this i don't think
he's going to win this position
but
he hasn't dropped any material or any
major concessions yet okay he's got some
weak squares but
you know that's i think a blessing for
him considering what could have been
yeah
i'm expecting white to just defend this
pawn you could for example defend it
with a rook um
you would love to defend it with the
queen as ivanka said but now i guess the
spawn is up for grabs so uh we need to
just keep an eye on this one i was
wondering briefly what happens if
white's knight goes to attack the rook
but there are a couple of safe squares
for it i guess it can just slide across
pretty safe temporarily and still
problems white from i guess the only one
is this isolated pawn
in the middle it's great if you keep it
but it is vulnerable
so
just defend live on and go active a bit
later
well the bar has definitely gone down
lavon is now left with four
minutes on the clock
yeah we
i like what he did in the game though
it's made it really exciting from move
one there have been kind of twists and
turns
mostly positive for white but still um
he's been
kind of giving lev on some different
types of headaches to what he's faced so
far in this final wow
surprising us all that is a very
surprising move give it away
what's his plan if that paul is just
captured
which it has to be right i guess his
queen wants to dive in right i mean this
is the only
the only move i can see but
risky stuff both under four minutes now
yeah again i guess we have to
investigate and the evaluation bar says
nope don't like it
so white's pawn stepping forward
too much pressure here black will take
this pawn
surely
yeah if the queen comes in yup white's
queen can jump in and i guess the black
knight which is attacked
can retreat back
at least the black knight has a nice
square
at least things are protected now for
black temporarily
well he's taking it without much force
there so we'll see yeah let's see what
the plan is seeing i guess the white
bishop can come and try and take this
pawn that might be one idea white's
knight could also jump forward at some
point but actually yeah i mean there's
counter play this pawn is hanging for
example
in some variations it's really
complicated suddenly after giving up
this pawn
i mean this guy is also attacked so
white's queen surely has to jump in what
else
very strange level and suddenly hand on
his head does he feel like he's losing
control yeah spending a lot of time
maybe just sensing the finishing line in
the match he's losing a bit of uh yeah
just losing his nerve slightly a little
bit impatient perhaps uh trying to
just put the ball in the back of the net
quickly and i don't think he even
thought that this move was possible i
think he probably just then oh the queen
dives in great position
and uh but uh that's a one move
calculation though i'm sure he saw that
the black knight can retreat yeah but
sometimes you sometimes people just make
assumptions that's what i'm trying to
say yeah and they just assume that these
kind of moves are you know passive it's
a bit weird
he's fallen into four here isn't it
ivanka then you know because
why why is he now thinking yeah you know
it's like
you know he's just he's just sacrificed
to pawn the guy's taking the pawn and
he's now thinking
seems odd he seems odd to do it that way
around so
two and a half minutes for lavon ironian
yeah he needs to find something now what
is he going to play is he can just
defend his central pawn is he going to
jump in with the white queen as we
showed
on
two minutes on the clock we
just over three minutes could see a
fight back we could see a fight back
maybe this is the luck that wei needs
and he's uh it's a lot easier playing in
his situation in a lot of ways because
you you
got nothing to lose right i mean like
you've probably lost the match you can
just play chess take pawns
um just play without any pressure
whatsoever okay so lev lev playing
this couldn't have been what he had
planned though surely this you know yes
now big question is can black capture a
pawn with this rook
black support uh blacks capture the f2
pawn it's
risky it's a bit loose for black but
that's the first move you want to
calculate right now for way e establish
a material advantage i guess levon his
idea is to just ignore everything on the
king side right now just go and grab a
pawn with his queen put pressure on
black's knight
lavon did slightly shake his head while
he was doing his usual stretching
okay black's rook
keeping the pawn alive
black's rook defends the fourth rank
that's quite a nice move actually just
hoping that white maybe step support up
to attack that rook because that would
weaken the white king structure
but it feels like the momentum is
shifting towards wei yi i mean i love
this rook on the fourth row and it can
actually centralize itself
and start looking at that uh
completely lonesome porn in the center
yeah love one shook his head again there
were you thinking
i mean so tempting to capture that white
f2 pawn i've got to say um
isn't it yeah
yeah it kind of feels like you're going
to get some attacking chances when you
take a pawn like that as well
i mean even if it's it's an illusion
but i i i think like yeah black black is
in the driving seat at the moment with a
slight time advantage
uh you could grab that pawn or or do the
move ivanka mentioned but the rook and
center looks looks very sensible as well
very very sensitive maybe that will lead
to mass exchanges though and a likely
draw i i think taking the pawn near the
king is the way to keep this game going
uh keep the complications alive
yeah
i mean in some positions as well black
central born the e pawn could step
forward just unleashing black's bishop
you might not want to do that yet but
um in the near future that's on the
cards where he has to move though both
sides at exactly
two minutes pretty much
it feels like this game will end up with
a winner
even if the bar is
in the middle of uh the bar it feels
that way
it feels that way i mean there's been so
much tension already it definitely feels
like it's heated up and where ye
didn't look happy for a second there why
was he i mean was he calculating
something then he realized oh it doesn't
work
he needs to move soon
um but okay he has to be practical
just over one and a half minutes left on
the clock and it's crunch time now is
his moment has to take a decision
and we are advocating that the rook
should just be bold and grab the pawn
closest to the king and then then things
will get very very spicy
and uh we could just see lavon ironian
you know he had
his hands
over his head
concentrating hard
getting ready for the ensuing mess
that's going to happen but now where ye
it's just over one minute it's not a
good time to have a long think no
i mean you've just spent two thirds of
your time on this position he had three
minutes and now he's got under a minute
that is not i mean this has been a
reoccurring issue uh his time handling
uh has has gotten him into a lot of
trouble that's how he looks okay he's
played he's played the move he wanted to
play and aronian quickly grabs that pawn
and now the move that david mentioned
releasing the bishop in front of the
black king this is really actually
heating up greatly now and uh
yeah getting very exciting yeah black's
bishop has some great potential suddenly
for the first time in the game and
black's bishop has just been a dead
piece of just a block of wood and now it
threatens to maybe come into the d4
square line up against the white king
line up against the white knight
black is also temporarily at least a
pawn up
i didn't see any way for white to
kind of win material here you can go and
grab a pawn for white and wow stockfish
the computer says there's only one move
to avoid defeat for levon ironian
and it's not 100 obvious
maybe by process of elimination he'll
get there but white's bishop has to take
a step back to challenge the black
bishop you have to go back to the c3
square try and trade off the bishops
right now i guess the idea actually is
that black's big threat is to swing the
like rook across behind the white queen
to attack it
utilizing the fact it's defended by
black's bishop so you prevent that big
big threat but that's counter-intuitive
retreating a piece well he has to do it
uh black has released his foundation
and
yeah well now we're seeing a few trades
but hang on a second
doesn't this favor white
because black's king is now looking a
little bit airy yeah and look at
stockfish again now
most moves give white decent advantage
black's only move to prevent a big white
advantage is to actually retreat the
black rook all the way to nowhere
well they will actually because there's
a huge threat on the board the knight is
threatening to come to the g4 square
attacking the rook and also threatening
knight takes pawn that is a killer move
yeah this is a massive threat oh sorry
not this one me and my arrows this is a
massive threat right now and uh as if
anchor mentions if black does nothing
black retreats the knight this hits the
rook and more importantly hits this pawn
with a deadly kind of night fork so he
has stopped this he stopped it in the
most kind of uh direct way here he just
brought his foot back to cover this
square but what happens if this rook is
kicked
or maybe yeah maybe it steps forward
i guess the rook if it's attacked will
step either back or into the white
position and now the queen can dive in
right
can you not just centralize here hit the
queen uh use the queen to hit the knight
maybe okay it has dived in instead in
the current position the white queen as
you mentioned ivanka hitting the knight
yeah things turning back and level on
aronian's favor it's very very loose and
it's all about the king safety this king
is weaker than its counterpart white
king's super safe actually yeah i mean
even if black's doing okay here the
issue is practically and now white can
just take the pawn and middleboard
getting his material back practically
king safety it's the most important
thing when you get short of time and
practically black's king very very
exposed white's king relatively safe
here um so
lev won't want to be exchanging queen
sir um
he can start going for the king get the
get the rookie lovely idea your knight
look at the white knight the white
knight is a superb piece it controls
checkmate squares it can jump forwards
it's a it's a brilliant piece in the
middle of the board and this is getting
he's played it again very exciting now
we might be about to see the final few
moves of uh the whole tournament because
this is a deadly czech threat and if
black just pushes a pawn for example or
does something this is a check and
black's queen will be skewered on the
seventh rank deadly threat and it's not
easy to prevent actually this check that
we're coming in to the seventh rank
ten seconds ten seconds i don't see how
to stop this
it is what he did this last i called
just just
with a few seconds left on his block he
offers a queen trade white can say no
why i can just reject this and drop back
with the queen if he really wants
white's queen can even jump in this
looks really scary though a check you
have to drop your knight back now
otherwise you get skewered yet again on
the seventh rank so you have to drop
your knight back
very passively hanging by a thread i can
kind of double pin your knight right now
he's gone given a check the black knight
has blocked
what else there must be a win for levon
worst comes the worst you just push a
pawn create some breathing space for
your king bring the white knight in to
the square that you guys were talking
about
and looks like everything's falling yeah
you've got two tempting squares for the
rook as well you've got the back rank
and you've got the ones supported by the
pawn uh trying to come over the the old
swinger uh operation and um both of
these both of these moves actually also
look good there's a lot of tempting
moves here for why i actually quite like
your h3 why not just play it safe but
he's gone he's gone in for an aggressive
move first of all black all the way back
now look how defensive it is for black
all these pieces stuck pinned trapped
and he does play this move this is just
a very kind of blitz rapid chest type of
move push up on make sure your king
won't get caught on the back rank you
have some breathing space big threat in
the position as well the white knight
coming in
and
wow okay the black queen slides across
trying to jump in with some checks were
ye fighting really hard actually yeah
this is this is a great resource from
where ye he might just have enough
counter play because he can get the
queens off in
a lot of positions if the knight jumps
in now surely that would help him with
very close well maybe a drawn ending
so
possibly lev missed this right i mean if
you continue with your night jump um
then yeah the queens get exchanged and
then black's king is in no danger
whatsoever and even though you might
lose a pawn here i think uh very good
drawing chances yep
the white king shuffles into the corner
really fascinating stuff are just
avoiding any checks for now
but levon's slightly shaking his head
black's still alive wei yi fighting for
his life in this tournament
wow the rooks are swinging in this game
the bar is swinging in this game
winning we're here winning it's a draw
who knows what this will end up with you
know it's a great move by wei yi
attacking the white rook and you can't
take that black knight because the white
rook would have fallen so we see a trade
suddenly
you talked about white tonight being
strong simon black's knight is equally
strong
yeah i think i think black's over the
worst now and uh well with this move
clearly uh lev is like okay draw listen
this is just agreeing that uh he's he's
missed his opportunity and we're going
to get another game you have to be
slightly careful as white the black king
will get very active soon but yeah as
simon says it should be a draw there's
not many pawns remaining and this will
eliminate a few more pawns this last
move
i'm just uh wondering whether we'll see
a moment like the last game where
suddenly one side self-destructs in a
drawn position
we can't write the game off too early
the last game we eat one move in a dead
drawn position and it was over yeah he
only has
20 seconds left now 25. yeah levon
was he's still playing for
he still may be playing for a win with
that move as well because he could have
he could have swapped off one more pawn
and
you know got a little bit closer to the
draw but this moves a little bit more
rare yeah uh playing for the win at
least now you can check maybe
we'll give a check
we'll step back
yeah and i was gonna ask
whether wei yi will be feeling bold
whether he will try and play for more
sensing that the tide is perhaps turning
i think it would be too risky for wei yi
i think at least if he survives this
game where he's been on the brink for a
long time at least he gets two more
games he'll
or at least the next one okay he is
playing for the win as black
wow i'm surprised at king f4 you know
yeah it's so bold
it's so unnecessary you know suddenly
white is a porn up but it's not any porn
it's the brooks pawn isn't it yeah it's
like the brooks pawn is
so good in a night ending
yeah
but the white knight is trapped right
the white knight is trapped white knight
has only one square to go to and that's
the top of the board you can go to the
g8 square but look at the evaluation bar
swinging again
that's the thing he's playing for wins
in position where in positions where he
should just get out of the game with a
draw same in the last game this one too
um at least if you drew this one with
white in a must-win situation maybe
slightly easier if you won that that's
the first step
okay the white knight does escape
and king is it going back to stop harry
the h-pawn there i think it has to i
think it's forced
uh 14 seconds and the clock is ticking
down for where he he has to keep an eye
on that runaway h pawn if he doesn't do
that he's running the risk of losing a
few seconds left three seconds when he
made that move retreating the white pawn
will simply step forward black's king
has to kind of chase that pawn now
and the white king is coming
is the one winning again maybe
it's on the brink between winning and
drawing for white right now there's no
chance black will win this game but why
would you ever go for this position as
wei yi
the black knight is currently doing a
good job creating a barrier stopping the
white king from kind of stepping forward
again but he just wanted to make the
game last a bit longer i mean
just push the h pawn okay he's done that
you know give it up and uh get the
knight out of his prison and win a pawn
make way ye suffer for some extra moves
and he doesn't have much time on the
clock yeah and of course it should be a
draw with only uh two white pawns left
but i think
that this will be a draw but i mean uh
okay and he's
okay he has one a porn at least
but he's got a he's got a
he's gotta still prove it he's going to
work hard for his money right well maybe
that's
i think he should clinch the draw with
this last move and ronin looking annoyed
there with yourself really annoyed
so he knows he i mean he was winning
for a whole chunk of the game but he
knows in deep in the end game he got
given another golden opportunity
but uh where he now looks pretty relaxed
he knows that this will go to a third
game the problem is for white the white
d pawn that's far advanced will be
stopped by the black king white's g porn
is just going to fall unless white goes
super passive with his king but if you
go passive with your king
that's not a good sign and uh
simply black's king is going to march
towards the d pawn eventually black's
knight is going to give itself up so
that
we can eliminate both the white pawns we
will see this happen
i'm expecting the black king now to just
go towards the white knight
there we go yeah and no way to keep both
the pawns alive
is there a trap in the position
small trap if the black king moves
across maybe but this is safe chess he
gives up the knight and eliminates the
final white pawn not enough check mating
material
it's a draw we will see a game three we
will see a game three by levonoronian is
uh still in the lead
and uh
he has to win game three to have any
hopes of taking this to tie breaks
game three will start in 15 minutes
levon looking